so um one of the guys wanted to ask you
what dating advice you'd give to young
guys
oh wow
um
that's so general is there is there a
more more specific or is it just just
that joke no no man folk honestly focus
on yourself dude focus on yourself don't
just chase women like become an awesome
man and women will eventually
chase you
um
like focus on focus on yourself and
focus on becoming
a guy who is
attractive and
you know a valuable person to society
and to everyone around you
and who is competent and who's skilled
and talented
and who has some semblance of resources
and then um
[Music]
yeah like that that's really the the
main
the main focus and then beyond that
you know if you're interested in a girl
like let her know you know don't be a
don't be a wuss like
be here you know
go go go for as a man you have to you
know
as a man like nothing good in the world
happens to you
just
by accident
right you have to you have to go out
there and you have to make it happen
like
men
put their will onto the world
right so
you whether you're talking health wealth
success finances relationships whatever
it is
you're you're not going to just like
stumble into
oh i oh look i tripped up and i'm
suddenly rich or i tripped up and i'm
suddenly ripped
oh wow i accidentally you know me you
know sometimes sometimes yeah maybe
there's some guy out there who you know
accidentally got a really hot girlfriend
or whatever but
like
generally you you have to
turn your
you have to use your own will and your
own skills and your own efforts
to make
things
happen that's just how it is being
you know a person to a degree but
certainly being being a man in the world
so my advice would be as a young guy you
know primarily don't don't waste all
your time in all your hours you know
just chasing and chasing and chasing
women um chase success and
yeah let women eventually be a byproduct
of that
um i was gonna ask would you give a
women different dating advice than men
yes what would you tell women to do
well i would say that women in general
and again i'm being intentionally broad
here someone's right stop generalizing
right right um but in general women
attract things
in the world right like women women
women attract like i was saying men
impose their will on the world
right and a woman can in certain in
certain areas right you know like in the
workplace or you know in her career
whatever she may do the same but
certainly when it comes to some other
aspects like women are more like
women women can afford to be more
passive shall we say right and attract
things to them as we know
generally in dating and relationships
like it's the guy who is
the active pursuant right whether it's
approaching the woman you know making
the first conversation you know paying
for the date you know deciding where to
go on the date it's
proposing like it's the guy who yeah is
the active
participant right and it's women who are
really like kind of like no no no yes no
right yeah i say men pick women shoes
right that's really that's the reality
of it and you know anyone who exists in
the real world whether or not they like
these kind of conversations that's just
the reality of it so
as a woman um yeah i would say that my
advice would absolutely be different and
i think people
do a massive disservice when they act
like men and women are
yeah identical and the advice for men
and women should just be the same just
you know oh yeah just do what a guy
would do it's like
no there's an overlap right
self-improvement self-improvement is is
an overlap right everybody right
everybody should strive to become
you know something approaching
approaching the best version of of
themselves physically mentally
spiritually personality like you know
all of that um
but what men are attracted to and what
women are attracted to
it's not the same you know anyone who
tells you that is a liar right yeah
they're deluded you know it's not it's
not the same thing which is how you get
these silly situations where you know a
woman is like some
high-flying career woman or whatever or
has like a
has a master's degree or a phd and she's
like yeah but like i've got this i've
got that and you know i'm like men don't
care like yeah
the girl who works in mcdonald's and
looks hot and feminine is more
attractive than the woman making six
figures and
whatever like unless she's also got
those attractive female qualities
guys don't generally just don't care
about that stuff but because a lot of
women are attracted to that or attracted
to you know statements et cetera then
they assume that guys are and i'm just
like no
it's not how it is no it's not how it's
ever been either that's the first
it's not how it's ever been um
and i think that you know feminism
perhaps has overshot so much that people
are in this delusion where they think
okay men are men and women are literally
the same and interchangeable
and it's like no and of course like
where there's nuance in all of this
every single person's an individual
has a different personality has a
different set of values different things
they're after so it's not
you know a one-size-fits-all
but generally speaking um just like i
could give advice you know generally for
a guy you know the advice generally
for a woman
would be um
[Music]
it would be different it would be
different i'd i'd also say like actually
for women it's a heck of a lot easier
i disagree
i think that it's easier for men dating
than women okay tell me tell me because
here's the thing women
um
they have a timeline right because you
have to what you're 35 to get married
like basically if you want to have kids
right
yeah roughly speaking and i just think
everything you don't want to leave it
too late yeah and i just think
everything's worse when you know you
have like a clock ticking where guys
have they could be 50 and still have
kids if they wanted to
sure
uh but yeah i mean you've still got a
long time i mean you got like well
that's like two decades
two decade what do you mean two no it's
like what are you gonna get married
like between 20 22. okay let's say women
have like what that's that's still like
15 years
yeah
okay
that's a long time
and most and most guys also don't really
actually want to wait until 50. i mean
you you can yeah
most guys don't want to so yeah sure men
have a longer window in that regard but
uh
yeah i mean the
yeah the the the game is heavily tilted
towards females i i i believe in my
opinion there are certain there's no
doubt that there are
certain things that are uh shall we say
easier like tilted in male in the male
favor and there are things that are
tilted
in the female favor but
i think generally certainly in the west
certainly in the modern west i think
it's a
it's a it's a it's a women's market more
than it's a man's market if you're like
in the top percent of guys then you may
think and feel very very differently on
this right for the average the average
woman compared to the average guy right
not even close if you're talking like
the tip top like you know a top guy and
however you want to rate that um
versus you know an average one then
that's that's different but
i don't know it's not designed to be an
average dude i just well i think that
men they can like become the things that
women want right i don't think women
like you're kind of born you look how
you look
no no no
no so no
no no most women can be attractive
oh
most women can be okay and in fact men
are attracted to most women most guys
won't admit this but most men are
attracted to most women unless they've
like
actually
gone out of their way to make themselves
unattractive
huh
yeah
which which can be a pretty high
percentage actually even if you just
look at i don't know obesity for example
like huge yeah yeah i mean if you look
at if you look at pictures from
just look at pictures from the
1970s or 1960s like most women are
attractive
huh
most of them are attractive i will say
that the one thing that you can't
overcome is being short as a guy
to be born short yeah it's a it's it's a
disadvantage i mean no i mean like look
if if a woman keeps her is a healthy
body weight
and you know
gross you know has a nice nice hairstyle
and just dresses nicely and is just you
know somewhat feminine
then
i mean that already puts her in probably
like top i don't know 25
right that's not right like that's not a
huge is it
depends on where you are like if you go
to like central europe or eastern europe
then no like that's not going to be at
the top but
like honestly the amount of people even
young people who this goes for men too
who just let themselves go already by
the age of like 20 is
pretty
pretty bonkers i mean i i also think
most men can be attractive like i think
most i think most people could be
attractive with like some moderate
effort and care
yeah yeah like like honestly you know i
mean if you take any guy off the street
um
you know whatever it's like okay get him
get him in the gym and eating well for
like
a year to two years
like get him a decent haircut
like if he's wearing like
just bad style like terrible clothes
just like you know swap that yeah it's
like okay like he'll
even physically he'll like already look
like pretty decent and then yeah you
know
other things you know confidence humor
all that like there's there's more to it
but
a lot of people the truth is a lot of
people don't put put very little
appearance
into
[Music]
even trying to be attractive that's
that's the truth like both men and women
like a lot of people just don't even try
and then a lot of times once people are
in relationships they try even less like
they just like whatever like yeah and so
merely trying
you're merely putting in some effort
whether you're a man or a woman already
is um
[Music]
yeah in this day and age like that's
already
that's already something that's already
something
yeah
yeah that's
i think he won this argument
i do think about these things a lot i've
thought about them from like a pretty
young age to be honest
i'm new to the manager i actually didn't
realize until recently the way people
treat you different just because you're
a girl
and i i did not realize that until super
recently like mine i do not realize that
well because you just think everyone's
treated like that i don't know
what
what specifically do you mean well okay
i'll give you i'll give you an example
right i i do um rap reactions on my
account right so um
my boyfriend he's very like into like
super like um freed frito bang i think
his name is
yeah those guys um i i don't i don't
listen to that that's not i listened to
country and he thought it was really
funny
watching me like react to these videos
because i didn't know what they meant
um it was like a stepa i didn't know
what that meant um i still don't but
he i wanted to get like a collab with
the rapper and get a reaction and like
they'll respond to me but he has over a
million followers on instagram and like
they don't respond to him
just because i'm a girl you know what
i'm saying just because i'm a girl
yeah yeah
so
there you go this is what i'm talking
about about the world being easier for
you yeah
it might sometimes be it might sometimes
be for the wrong reasons but it's just
how it is i just proved your point but
sorry i think i think i just went over
our time but this is fine it's fine
this was so fun though um thank you so
much for coming on i know you have a
bigger platform than me so i was
actually really excited that you said
yes
you're welcome you're welcome well if
people want to check my stuff out you
can follow me at zooby music on all
platforms twitter instagram facebook
youtube
and um
if you go to zoobeemusic.com i've got
all of my music podcasts merch links to
everything on there so you can check
that out